- Nice to meet you!
- [Topher] Pleasure to meet you.
- Yeah, meet Topher,
he likes cheeseburgers.
- I miss you.
(guests laughing)
Who doesn't?
- I know. I miss you too.
You're always working
though. I'm always working.
- You're always working.
I'm already hooked to the pillow.
- Someone was actually, that's okay.
It's a very cute outfit.
- Thanks.
It's giving a little
bit of yee-haw energy.
Had to do it.
- Love it.
It's like yee-haw and rock and roll.
Plus some business.
- A little Harry Styles
moment, too.
- And that's always a good moment.
I like his style.
- It is.
He is the moment.
- No pun intended.
People were asking me backstage,
they were like, "You've
known her for a while."
I was like, yes, I've
known her for a while.
- And now, we have a song together.
- (gasps) We do.
Me, you, and Carly Pearce.
- We do. It just came out.
- I can't actually tell
that full story on TV,
but it's quite funny, that
recording day for me. (laughs)
- I asked Kelly to be a part
of my song in the morning,
and she went to the studio
that night and did vocals.
- Wow.
- So, you know what, I'm gonna
give you a little bit of it.
So, it's my last day of work.
I have told Trisha, my assistant
and my group, I'm like,
"I can't do anything."
I will not.
- The day I texted you?
- The day you texted me.
I had literally been like, look,
this has to be my last day, then I'm off.
I was like, I promised myself this summer.
And not only you text
me, but Shane McAnally,
our friend who's also a singer-songwriter.
And, anyway he, you both texted me,
and they were like, "Oh we got this song."
And I was like, oh, I love Kelsea.
I was like, okay, lemme just listen to it.
And I was like, oh, I have to do this.
Well, I had already been celebrating-
- I do know this story.
- I had already been celebrating that it
was my last day of work.
Mkay, so I get to the studio,
here at this studio with Jason,
and I get in there and I'm like, look,
I didn't know I was
gonna be singing today.
I was like, I don't know, so I had to sing
a song called 'You're
Drunk Go Home' inebriated,
trying to sing for soprano
parts like I'm fine.
Like, there is an actual full track,
we have to send it to
you, of me just crying
and laughing so hard I
almost peed my pants.
- Please do.
- 'Cause I was like,
this has never happened to me in 20 years.
I've never ever been inebriated
while singing something,
and I am while singing
'You're Drunk Go Home'.
- There is this mo-
(audience cheering)
- It's a great song.
It's a great song.
- There's one ad lib
on the track.
- I didn't know,
I had already started and then you texted.
- There's one part on
the song where it's like
an ad lib track and now
you're gonna hear it
and now you're gonna know.
And you just hear Kelly go, "Bye."
And it's in there and it's cranked.
So thank you for that.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you for that.
- I was like, I felt so bad.
Has that ever happened to you?
- On set, have you ever?
- I didn't know!
No, because I would
never do it.
- Oh, I'm drunk
every time you see me.
- Every time.
- He's drunk right now.
No, I just, nobody had told me.
So I'd already celebrated
and then I got it
and it was already too late.
- I just, I gotta hear this song.
- It's a great song.
It's a great song.
- Yeah, it's meant to
feel kind of like you're
at a bar anyway.
- I was at an
actual bar.
- Bar.
- Yeah, and it turned out so funny.
Okay, I wanna talk about
your new album now.
I love the title, 'Subject to Change'.
- Yeah, thanks.
- This is a,
I think titles are everything,
'cause you kind of have to encompass
what all is happening on it.
And I love it.
- Thank you.
- So like,
why 'Subject to Change?'
Why does that count?
- Every record I've gotten
to make has kind of been
a snapshot of like the two years
of my twenties that I wrote it during.
And when I was listening to
the demos I was like, man,
I'm writing a lot about kind
of like this stark contrast
and juxtaposition that I've
been feeling as I've grown up
and entered into my late twenties and so,
I just, I loved the idea of
taking the polarizing feeling
and the fear away from the word, 'change',
and going like, if I just embrace it,
'cause it's gonna happen inevitably, like,
can I find joy in it?
And it's kind of that journey.
- I actually do find joy in change.
And I don't know if it's
from childhood trauma
where a lot of change happened.
- Same.
- You know, a lot of
change happened regardless
of me wanting it, you know?
Or the desire, but I think
it actually did enable me
to like embrace it rather
than be so fearful.
'Cause people can be
very fearful of change.
I love it. What about you?
Are you good with change
or no?
- No, I fear change.
(audience laughing)
- I love you so much.
- But I mean, we all fear change.
We're trying to embrace it, right?
- Yeah, it's a journey.
- I don't. I don't fear it.
I think because of whenever
I was younger just so much,
that I just had to kind
of learn that it could,
'cause you never, I think people fear it
because you don't know what's
on the other side, right?
You don't know
what's gonna happen.
- I always think this too
shall pass and that means,
you know, good things will,
that will pass but also bad
things will pass too, right?
- Or come. (laughs)
You're like, eh.
But you recently went back
to your high school reunion.
I never got to do that.
- I did.
- I didn't even know mine happened.
So, like, so yeah, what was that like?
Were they freaking out?
- It was half and half, I gotta be honest.
So this was the high school
that I left after my sophomore
year to move to Nashville
to do this.
So I didn't graduate here.
So I was kind of like an honorary bobcat.
But my best friend graduated
from there and I went with her
and it was so interesting
'cause we walked in the room
and people were having dinner
and it was the same people.
- Cliques?
- At the tables!
Yeah, that was after we drank.
- Yeah, see this is, by the
way, this is what it looked like
in the studio when I was
recording 'You're Drunk Go Home'.
- This is why we're friends.
- Yeah, yeah, we're similar.
- It was really beautiful
because it was actually
the 11 year reunion and
it was just really cool
to see everyone and everyone's
in a different phase of life
but, you know, we're all
just growing up and it's like
a really cool, it was really,
I don't know, heartfelt.
- Oh I love that.
I didn't even know mine existed.
Whenever they were.
I'm like old now so
there's probably been many.
But wait, were you, what
were you like in high school?
We know you weren't as
popular as Frank but-
- Yeah, Frank.
- [Kelly] How was it?
- I went to a boarding
school so I loved it.
But I wanted to go, it
wasn't one of those,
a lot of people think when I tell them
that I was sent there by my parents.
But I actually enjoyed
it and wanted to go.
And it was kind of like mini college.
But who's the guy?
Who was the guy who
you saw at your reunion
who you said, now I'm this person?
- Was there a guy?
- There wasn't a guy.
- Oh, come on.
- Was there a girl?
Wait, was that? I was like, wait, what?
- It's 'cause I always dated older guys.
- Yeah so.
- That's also a little
bit of childhood trauma.
(Kelsea laughs)
Me too.
- Okay.
Oh well, no segue there.
We need to take a break but stick around
because Kelsea and her band are performing
for us later in the show.
It's such a great song,
you'll wanna see it.
Once again, her new album is
called 'Subject to Change'.
It is, it's out now.